pas commencer par le trou français pour
que tu pourrais rééquilibrer le la
gauche est plus haut et à droite le
cadre entendent donc voilà c'est notre
au dessus
quand est ce que tu peux des billets
verts en allant vers la gauche tout
doucement et d'y perdre leur licence de
speed de faire d'éclat le sol
large qu'en avant qu'on arrive dessus
stocker avec toute la grippe et ouais
et la terre quant à la bo loin au loin
et j'avais de revin
les barges way d'autant plus que ce
qu'un pas cool de fumée de devis mais
les après avoir balayé avec les ligues
beau c'est pas cool de revenir ce n'est
pas pour fumer non mais ça ne trouve pas
faim oui si si mais c'est comme ça c'est
comme un village de réfugiés en algérie
fusionna us a aussi fait de sa mère
découpage facilement entre eux il n'y
avait pas de faire la union non non non
les panais revoit toutefois que je
trouve parole est pas sûr que le vert
avec le laser c'est qu'ils sont pas il
ya des heures quand même un peu de
verdure autorisée a que dalle quoi
vraiment mieux
ben y'en avait quoi bah y'en a vraiment
quoi oui voilà c'est sans doute quoi
donc aux questions capoue fond du court